je vous demande de dire où sont ces 250
individus qu'elle est qu'elles sont les
poursuites pénales qui seront engagées
contre eux merci la parole est à mme
monsieur bernard cazeneuve ministre de
l'intérieur s'il vous plaît allez
retrouver votre calme
je vous ai le ministe c'est le
gouvernement qui veut faire ici elle est
le ministre qui répond vous le savez
allez monsieur le monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les députés
je voudrais d'abord vous remercier pour
la chaleur de votre accueil qui me va
droit au coeur
c'est toujours agréable sur les sujets
les plus importants qui devraient
appeler le rassemblement le plus grand
que de voir des polémiques inutiles
poindre mais la lutte contre le
terrorisme vous le savez bien
monsieur j appelle l'engagement de
nombreux ministères et sur la question
de la lutte contre le terrorisme
le ministère de la justice et le
ministère de l'intérieur comme en
témoigne l'excellence des relations
entre le parquet antiterroriste françois
molas et les services de police agissent
de concert
alors vous me posez une question
extrêmement précise et je vais y
répondre il y à 250 personnes qui sont
revenus sur le théâtre des opérations
terroristes après le retour de décence
de ses 250 personnes
il ya eu 2 130 deux interpellations
il ya eu 168 incarcération il y a eu 60
contrôle judiciaire
par conséquent monsieur marc l'ex
lorsque vous laissez à entendre à la
représentation nationale et par
conséquent aux français qu'il n'y aurait
pas de fermeté face au terrorisme qui
rentre d opération terroriste
après ce que je viens de vous indiquer
vous maniez la contrevérité et le sujet
de la lutte contre le terrorisme mérite
beaucoup mieux que les contre-vérités et
les mises en cause a jusqu'au ministre
qui comme la garde des sceaux sur la
question de la lutte contre le
terrorisme donnent le meilleur d'eux
mêmes
prennent les décisions qui doivent être
prises et les français je suis allé à la
détermination qu'elano et qui savent que
cette détermination sera sur le métier
jour après jour car la guerre contre le
terrorisme nous la gagnerons